I'm just the latest lucky subject to
contribute a saliva sample at J & JS
oral care lab in New Jersey is there a
technique to this Jane J researchers
regularly collect saliva donations from
colleagues grow bacteria and compare
mouth germs before and after using
Listerine so why do you keep doing these
tests over and over if it's obvious that
was during work so why do you keep
taking samples from people we're always
looking to improve the formulation do
germs change that much the germs don't
change but we're constantly changing the
formula why the constant changes
considering Listerine is already a core
J&J brand with nearly 1.8 billion
dollars in sales and growing and is the
number one brand globally with 36% of
the market beating Colgate Plax crest
oral-b and scoped by a wide margin
it's the potential for emerging market
and international growth that keeps J &
JS oral care lab humming take the
asia-pacific industry researchers expect
the oral care market to grow at an
average annual rate of 5 percent in the
next five years that's more than double
the rate in North America the growth
that we have seen in Asia lately
especially 2013 was impressive so our
focus on the emerging markets is
something that we're putting a lot of
effort to go after those faster growing
emerging markets means constant
experimentation in a place where J&J has
never allowed cameras before
this is our room where we grow the vial
[ __ ] okay so we still early you're
smelling all the bad breath bacterias
here is where we would grow the bacteria
they'll incubate in here for five days
so what we have here is all of the
bacteria that are present in someone's
mouth there's a lot before brushing and
it's like oh my god it really smells
like bad breath after rinsing with
Listerine for 30 seconds we see result
like this
it's experiments in these rooms that
have helped to produce the 25 different
Listerine sold globally including green
tea Listerine for consumers in Asia use
three natural 15 and the quest for the
next formulation continues grow bacteria
grow biofilms and killed